so the topic today is on nutrient dense foods
there are certain nutrients that are very easy
to get and some that are very very difficult
probably out of all the nutrients the one that
is the most difficult is vitamin d in fact it's
next to impossible to get the vitamin d that
you need from foods this is why we have the sun
right now probably one of the vitamins that is
the easiest to get is probably vitamin k1 not k2
but vitamin k1 which is has anti-clotting factors
and i would say b6 is pretty easy to get to it's
in so many different foods but the problem is
a requirement for potassium is so high we need
4700 milligrams that that's another one that's
difficult to get unless you're consuming a lot
of vegetables minimally seven cups now you can
also get potassium from meats as well so you want
to include all of your foods to figure out your
potassium levels magnesium is another one that
a lot of people are deficient in but if you're
consuming enough vegetables you're going to
get magnesium but magnesium is another mineral
that a lot of people are deficient in and it's a
very necessary mineral to act as a cofactor for
a lot of different chemical reactions in the
body all right now let's talk about vitamin a
this is a very confusing topic because you'll see
certain videos and blog articles on vitamin a is
in spinach it's in kale you have to realize
that is a pre vitamin a it's not the actual
bioavailable active form of vitamin a called
retinol it's mainly in a beta-carotene form
which is a precursor so you have to convert it and
rarely does anyone get any significant amount of
retinol from consuming vegetables because number
one the conversion factor is so low and on top of
that 45% of the population has a mutation with
their genes that doesn't allow them to convert
the pre-vitamin a to the active form of vitamin
a and one of the best sources of active retinol
would be in organ meats it would be in egg yolks
now the next one i want to talk about is omega-3
fatty acids another one that is a bit difficult to
get unless you're consuming fatty fish organ meats
grass-fed animal products now you can get
omega-3 fatty acids in algae and seafood
etc but the precursor to the omega-3 fatty acid
dha is something called ala which is in walnuts
it's in other plants it's in certain seeds but
the conversion factor is very very small so even
though ala is an omega-3 fatty acids it's kind of
like a precursor it's not the actual important dha
omega-3 fatty acid itself now the next set of
nutrients i want to talk about is trace minerals
many many many people are deficient in trace
minerals simply because unless you're consuming
food from the sea or sea kelp or shellfish you're
not going to get a lot of trace minerals however
there are a good amount of trace minerals and
organ meats as we kind of go through this list and
talk about what foods have certain key nutrients
that will give you a really good idea on what you
should be eating or what diet you should be on
and then we get to the topic of iron you have
heme iron which is a bio-available iron which is
in animal products and then you have non-heme iron
which are in vegetables and plants like spinach
for example which is not very available to you so
the most bioavailable iron is from animal products
so as you can see as we're going in the list
a perfect diet would be a combination of plant
foods and animal foods and let's not forget b12
b12 is in animal products now plants do give us
a good amount of vitamin c and you can get a good
amount of vitamin c from berries like blueberries
blackberries which have a low glycemic index now
many people are trying to get their vitamin c from
fruit the problem is that there's just too much
sugar and fruit and the fruit nowadays has been
grown with high levels of sugar carbohydrates so
we're not going to recommend that but you can
get a good amount of vitamin c from vegetables
which are low in sugar even though they're high
in carbohydrate but a lot of that carbohydrate is
fiber which does not affect your blood sugars now
even though antioxidants and phytonutrients that
are in our foods are not classified as essential
nutrients i'm going to add this to the list simply
because there's so many benefits of these
phytonutrients for example the phytonutrients
in garlic anti-cancer antimicrobial are off
the charts so a lot of spices and herbs and
classes of vegetables like cruciferous give
you additional nutrients like phytonutrients
that go way beyond just the essential nutrients
that most people think with so if we take a look
at the foods that are most nutrient dense
at the top of the list we have organ meats
grass-fed liver of course grass-fed heart and
brains are loaded with bioavailable nutrients
so you don't need much of it but a little bit
on a regular basis would be very very helpful
plus vitamin k2 which i haven't really talked
about is in organ meats it's in fatty meats
it's in egg yolks it's in grass-fed dairy and
then we get shellfish which not only has the
omega-3 fatty acids but it's loaded with
trace minerals and vitamins and minerals
salmon great source of omega-3 fatty acids
plus it has trace minerals and a great source
of protein as well and then before we have
cruciferous vegetables so we have great amounts
of phytonutrients that are anti-cancer but we
also have potassium magnesium trace minerals
vitamin c but we're not getting retinol from
cruciferous vegetables number five i put in here
salads or leafy greens for your potassium and your
magnesium plus it has vitamin c and a lot of other
great nutrients as well a lot of the b
vitamins as well number six grass-fed
meats have a really good spectrum of nutrients
a great diversity of b vitamins and minerals
and even antioxidants and then we get to the topic
of eggs now the protein in eggs is very different
than the protein you would get from meat we're
dealing with an embryo which gives you very unique
types of nutrients versus animal muscle protein
but the egg yolk is loaded with the active form
of vitamin a which is retinol the egg has a great
balance of nutrients pretty much every nutrient
except vitamin c it may have a small amount of
vitamin c but nothing significant but the egg
yolk has choline which prevents the fatty liver
helps your nervous system it has virtually all the
fat soluble vitamins including k2 so we definitely
don't want to neglect the egg i already mentioned
fruits have too much sugar potatoes actually have
a good amount of potassium and other nutrients
like vitamin c but they're high in starch so even
though it may have some nutrients i'm not going
to add that to the list now even though grains
have certain nutrients okay like the b vitamins
they are high in phytates which block certain
trace minerals so they have properties of
anti-nutrients and plus they are also high in
carbs there are certain vegetables that are high
in oxalates like spinach for example and rhubarb
which will block calcium and they can also add a
lot of other problems to your life like they can
give you arthritic pains as well as kidney stones
so even though spinach and swiss chard has a lot
of nutrients it also has anti-nutrients as well
and other compounds like tannins in tea and
coffee have factors that deplete nutrients as well
but really only if you're consuming large
quantities in them so if you're drinking tea
all day long and coffee it could be depleting a
lot of key nutrients unless you put those back in
all right guys so there you have it the seven most
nutrient-dense foods before you go if you have a
question about a product or you're new to keto
and you want to know how to begin keto or you're
on keto and you need a debug because it's not
going as smooth i have a keto consultant standing
by to help you this is just for the people in
the u.s hopefully in the future we'll be able
to answer everyone's call but i put the number
down below so you can call and get some help